hey 42 here on the 4th of April 1922 six
bodies were discovered on a small
Bavarian Farm known as hin kek about 40
Mi north of Munich it was a tragic and
shockingly brutal event but if that's
where this story ended I probably
wouldn't be making a video about it a
100 years later it's a sad reality of
the modern world that people get
murdered quite a bit about once per
minute globally according to the World
Health Organization so why am I making a
video about six murders on a small
Bavarian Farm 100 years ago well because
what happened that night is quite simply
one of the most chilling and downright
baffling crimes in history with some
very strange twists along the way and by
the end of this video you'll uncover
what footprints in the snow a missing
key and an incestuous relationship have
in common but first I want to ask you a
question what would you do if you heard
strange noises coming from your attic
well that's exactly what hin kek Farms
live live in maid reported about 6
months before the murders old farmhouses
aren't exactly known for being quiet
places but these sounds were different
disturbing even Footprints scratching
tapping it was almost as though someone
was secretly living in the Attic that
someone if he or she ever existed was
never found but the maid was so
frightened she quit her job on the spot
never to return fast forward 6 months
just a few days before the murders and
the Farm's owner a man called Andreas
Gruber found a set of footprints in the
snow leading from the nearby Forest to
the farm again a search of the premises
didn't turn up any mischievous murderers
playing the world's least funny game of
hide and seek but they didn't find any
Footprints leading away from the farm
either that night the entire family
heard strange noises coming from the
attic and the following day Andreas
Gruber noticed that one of his house
keys had gone missing more on that in a
minute skillshare is the largest online
learning community for creatives with
thousands of classes led by industry
Pros across film illustration design
freelance productivity and more this New
Year invest in yourself and your goals
by starting a Learning Journey on
skillshare to take your career your
skills or your side hustle to the next
level if you're not sure where to start
then skillshare has designed learning
paths to help you get from novice to Pro
in no time at all learning paths are
curated sequential class collections to
master a specific skill or competency
with learning paths you can know exactly
where to start your Learning Journey
skillshare has curated high quality
content in the category of your choice
so you have clear direction to achieve
your goal and you'll discover new to you
teachers each learning path is curated
by category and includes classes from a
variety of teachers to help you discover
new industry Pros to learn from recently
I've been trying to level up the
animation in our videos so I've been
following following the learning path go
from idea to finished animation as a
beginner it's been an absolute blast and
a GameChanger for my animation skills
for me following a learning path instead
of blindly choosing a course ensured
that my learning was efficient and
directed the first 500 people to use my
link will get a one Monon free trial of
skillshare so don't miss out the links
in the description and a big thanks to
skillshare for sponsoring this
video a few days later on the 31st of
March Maria borm Gartner arrived at Hind
kek she was to be the group of family's
new maid you know to replace the one
that quit her job in Terror 6 months
earlier yeah I'm guessing they didn't
mention that in the interview we've all
heard horror stories about bad first
days at work you might have one or two
yourself but I don't think anyone can
top Maria bound garders because that
very night she and all five of her new
employers were brutally
murdered exactly what happened is still
unknown but from what we can tell the
murderer hid in the bar then somehow LED
four members of the Gruber family to his
location one by one Andreas Gruber his
wife cazila their daughter Victoria
Gabriel and her daughter also called
cazila were later found dead on the
floor of the barn their bodies were
stacked on top of each other one by one
from there the killer moved into The
Farmhouse where he murdered the new maid
in her bedroom 2-year-old Yosef Gabriel
Victoria's youngest child was found dead
in his cot all six of the victims were
killed in the same way bludgeoned over
the head with a blunt
object so far so horrific and combined
with the noises from the attic and
footprints in the snow it's all pretty
bloody weird too but what happened next
is stranger still it was four full days
before the bodies were discovered that
in itself isn't particularly surprising
the farm was relatively remote but what
is surprising in is the fact that
several witnesses reported seeing Signs
of Life there in the days after the
killings the evening after the murderers
local Carpenter Michael plle passed by
the farm on his way home from work he
remembered seeing smoke coming from the
chimney and A man carrying a torch
walking around the yard 2 Days Later
mechanic Albert Hoffner spent more than
5 hours on the farm fixing a diesel
engine Andreas grber had booked the
appointments the previous week hufner
didn't see a soul whilst he worked but
when when he left he did notice that
someone had opened the door to the barn
and tied up the family dog near the
front door police would later find that
in the days after the murders someone
had been tending to the Farm's animals
milking the cows feeding the dog that
sort of thing there was also evidence
that meals had been prepared and
consumed in the Farm's kitchen
considering all members of the gruba
family were well and truly dead at this
point there's only one real conclusion
we can come to here after murdering six
people in Cold Blood the killer
continued to live on the property with
his victims for 4 days just being a
farmer the things people did before
starj Valley okay it's time to ask that
most important of questions what kind of
sadistic Maniac could have done such a
thing suspicion first fell on the grba's
closest neighbor fellow farmer Loren
shilen it was he along with his friends
Michael Paul and Jacob seek who first
found their bodies on the afternoon of
the 4th of April they'd gone to check on
the family after realizing nobody had
seen them for several days rumor has it
shilon was in a relationship with one of
the victims Victoria but the real reason
police suspected he was involved is
because according to official statements
from Paul an he'd acted really bloody
weird when he found the bodies the first
course of action for most people upon
finding four dead bodies piled up in a
barn would be to throw up all over their
own shoes not Loren shilter B nope he
decided to move them around a bit to get
a better look at them apparently showing
no particularly strong emotions he then
headed into The Farmhouse unlocking the
front door with a key he produced from
his own pocket Paul and seek tried to
stop him on the grounds that they
shouldn't disturb any evidence that
might be useful to the police but shilon
Bower ignored them and just went in
alone when the police did finally show
up the following day he was even kind
enough to present them with what he
thought was the murder weapon
a pickaxe he'd found in the barn I can
only assume he was either very naive or
very very guilty he was later question
by the police for obvious reasons but he
justified his undeniably odd behavior by
claiming he'd been frantically searching
for his son and this is where things
start to get a bit complicated well more
complicated you see the paternity of 2y
year-old Yosef Gabriel the youngest
victim is unclear his mother Victoria
had been widowed 8 years earlier when
her husband Carl died fighting in the
first world war that was a good 6 years
before Yosef was born so he was the
father well according to Loren shilon
Bower he was or at least that's what he
claimed after the murders beforehand he
swore blind that he wasn't although it's
possible he was just trying to get out
of paying child support either way
there's another strong Contender for
Yo's father Andreas
Gruber yeah that's Victoria's own Dad it
was well known in the local community
that Andreas and Victoria were involved
in an incestuous relationship they'd
even been forced to deny it in court
their accuser Loren schenauer I told you
it was complicated shilow eventually
dropped those charges and it seems that
they all kissed and made up afterwards
sorry poor choice of words there but
when he later asked permission to take
Victoria's hand in marriage Andreas
Gruber
refused yeah I don't know why why he
wanted to marry the woman he thought was
sleeping with her own father either
basically it's all one big incestuous
mess and we'll likely never know all the
details the important thing here is that
there may well have been a pretty
powerful motive for murder buried in
there somewhere did Loren shilen Bower
believe Yosef was his only to find out
Andreas was really the father it's
certainly possible add that to the other
evidence against him and it isn't hard
to see why shilon Bower was suspect
number one but question marks still
remain arguably the most compelling
evidence against him is the fact he
seems to have deliberately tampered with
the evidence when the bodies were
discovered but just think about it if he
really was the killer he would have had
a full 4 days to prepare the scene it
makes no sense whatsoever that he would
have waited until there were witnesses
to try and cover up his tracks and if he
really was yose's Father which is
perfectly possible his actions that day
actually make a lot of sense because he
would have been absolutely frantic
trying to find his son son seeing a pile
of bodies in the barn he would have had
to make sure Yosef wasn't amongst them
and after confirming the boy wasn't in
the barn he would have headed straight
for the house waiting around for the
police to show up just wouldn't have
been an option for him then there's that
key again it seems quite suspicious at
first considering we know one had just
gone missing but it isn't exactly
unheard of for people to give their
neighbor spare keys and if shilon Bower
really was in a relationship with
Victoria then it's even more reasonable
that he would have had a key to the farm
whatever the truth the police were
ultimately unable to find enough
evidence to formally charge him though
he would fight accusations that he was
the killer for the rest of his
life there are plenty of unknowns
surrounding the hint of kek case but one
thing the police have been fairly
certain of all along is that the killer
knew the family well nothing was stolen
so it couldn't have been a robbery and
the way the grubers were systematically
eliminated
seems to suggest a deep-seated personal
Vendetta rather than a random act of
violence that's obviously nared things
down quite a bit and believe it or not
for a while it led to one of the leading
suspects being a dead man we already
know that Victoria's husband Carl
Gabriel died 8 years before the murders
whilst fighting in the first world war
but there's something interesting about
his death that I haven't mentioned so
far his body was never recovered and
that got people wondering was it
possible that Carl Gabriel didn't die in
the war after all that he returned home
after an 8-year absence to find his wife
had had a child with another man
possibly her own father combin that
nasty shock with a healthy dose of
trauma From The Trenches and who knows
what the prodigal son-in-law might have
been capable of okay admittedly that
does all sound a bit far-fetched but
police at the time actually took this
Theory extremely seriously Not only
would calll Gabriel have had a strong
motive him being the killer would also
have explained some of the weirder
elements of the case after all it's very
hard to imagine why a killer would ever
willingly choose to live in his victim's
house after committing the crime unless
it was actually his house too it was an
interesting Theory But ultimately it's
almost certainly not true the police
were able to track down many of Carl's
fellow soldiers from his time in the war
and several offered matching
descriptions of when where and how he
died the fact his body wasn't recovered
might seem suspicious at first until you
remember that 10 million soldiers died
during the first world war there's also
the fact that one of the victims in the
hint kek murders was cazila Gabriel who
so far as we know was car's own daughter
whilst the safe money is on Carl
definitely not being the killer about 30
years after the murders took place in
the early 1950s a German newspaper
published a series of stories about the
case tued away amongst them was a report
claiming that several witnesses saw a
mysterious stranger in the woods near
the farm in the days leading up to the
murders this unidentified man appeared
to be spying on the family and how's
this for an interesting little detail he
was apparently wearing a military
uniform during the course of the
investigation the police considered more
than a hundred different suspects but
every single one of them turned out to
be a dead end it didn't help that the
the investigation itself was a bit of a
shambles actually it was a lot of a
shambles after the crime was first
phoned in it was more than 3 hours
before the munic police force dispatched
any officers to the scene and this crack
team of top detectives then somehow
managed to drive to the wrong Farm
entirely by the time they arrived at hin
kek dozens of locals had turned up to
see what all the fuss was about some
sources even claim Loren shilen Bower
was giving guided tours of the bodies
and there are are several reports that
someone had made themselves a bite to
eat in the kitchen many of the forensic
techniques in news today hadn't been
invented back then but even the ones
that had weren't actually used
fingerprinting was standard practice at
the time but for some reason none was
carried out on hint to kek and the
detective inspector in charge of the
case only spent half a day at the scene
just five crime scene photographs were
taken and the property was seared so
poorly that it wasn't until hint kek was
demolished a year later that the real
murder weapon was found a matok that had
been hidden beneath the floorboards on
the ground floor of the house over the
decades multiple Munich police Chiefs
would have a go at cracking the case but
hampered by a lack of evidence it
remains unsolved to this day not that
people have given up trying in 2017
almost 100 years after the murders took
place American author Bill James and his
daughter Rachel published a book called
The Man from the Train which
investigates a series of apparently
unrelated murders that took place in the
US between 1898 and 1912 I say
apparently unrelated because it turns
out there were quite a lot of
similarities between the crimes in most
cases theilla murdered an entire family
in their relatively remote home he
killed by striking his victims over the
head with a blunt object usually one he
found at the scene and he had a curious
habit of stacking the bodies when he was
finished with his bloody work sound
familiar the man from the train isn't
about hint to kek at all but the offers
make the connection right at the end and
for a good reason you see the man they
believed committed the murders in
America just so happens to have been a
German immigrant and ex soldier called
Paul Mueller according to the book
Mueller's last American victims were
killed in Iowa in 1912 by that point the
authors believed he'd murdered around 50
people and they theorized that worried
the US copter on to him mu fled back to
Germany if that's the case it's
certainly possible that he was indeed
the hin kek killer it's a genuinely
intriguing idea the details of these
crimes really are eily similar the
timelines roughly match up and it's a
funny old coincidence that Mueller was
German but the truth is there's no
evidence that he ever went back to
Germany until we find some this one's
still just a theory these days famous
cold cases tend to attract their fair
share of Internet sloths and hint is no
exception for the most part these
digital detectives have focused on one
aspect of the case that police seem to
have largely overlooked the strange
goings on at the farm in the leadup to
the murders between the footprints in
the snow the noises in the attic and the
missing house key it isn't hard to
imagine that the killer whoever he was
had been living on the farm in secret
for some time before the murders could
it have been a Drifter who took shelter
on the farm then decided to murder the
grubers after learning all of their groy
secrets again it's a nice Theory but
again there's scant concrete evidence to
support it and the same can be said for
pretty much all the other theories too
the truth is we may never know what
exactly happened on that farm 100 years
ago too much time has passed and too
little evidence has survived one thing's
for certain though the hind kek murders
are one of the most disturbing and
morbidly fascinating unsolved crimes in
history my final question to you you is
this who do you think did it thanks for
watching just a quick word to say that I
couldn't make these videos without the
support of my patreon members consider
joining the exclusive 42 Discord
Community by supporting me on patreon
it's a great place to discuss my videos
with like-minded individuals and myself
the Link's in the description but if you
don't want to or you can't join my
patreon then please don't worry a simple
like or comment to say thanks would also
put a huge smile on my face thank you